dans un mariage il n'y a pas que les
bulles de champagne qui peuvent faire
tourner la tête le prix aussi la
priorité numéro une pour les mariés
sélectionner le lieu dans les yvelines
un business s'est développé celui des
salles de prestige on retrouve des
dizaines de lieux à des prix pouvant
aller de 5000 à 20000 euros pour une
soirée l'un des plus connus l'abbaye des
vaux de cernay un domaine cisterciens
construit au 12e siècle pour se payer
cette part d'histoire il faut faire
chauffer la carte bleue
une centaine d'individus il faut compter
un ticket moyen
si je peux parler ainsi en termes
hôtelier a minima aux alentours d'une
centaine d'euros pouvoir aller jusqu'à
150 euros à 150 euros par personne bon
nombre de jeunes mariés se sacrifie pour
pouvoir s'offrir l'abbaye des vaux de
cernay
c'est un événement unique dans leur vie
donc ils savent aussi faire la part des
choses parfois même emprunté lourdement
pour se faire plaisir à l'abbaye
l'abbaye accueille aujourd'hui entre 50
et 70 mariages chaque année certains
clients n'hésitent pas à parcourir des
milliers de kilomètres pour venir fêter
le plus beau jour de leur vie
le bouche à oreille fonctionne très bien
beaucoup de mariages américain beaucoup
de mariages libanais la communauté
libanaise a mis le pied à l'abbaye il ya
quelques années on les mariages
généralement très somptueux qui
s'étendent généralement sur deux voire
trois jours
autre élément incontournable d'un
mariage les fleurs dans le département
les mariés et leurs familles peuvent
dépenser entre 500 et 1500 euros pour se
faire une place sur ce marché ultra
concurrentiel ce fleuriste implantée à
villepreux n'hésite pas à suivre les
dernières tendances
ces derniers temps surtout vous avez
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui sont mis
en place dans la décoration on est
vraiment sur une mode qui est sûre du
champêtre
une mode qui est sûre du naturel du
romantique les mariés sont vraiment
friand de petites décorations de détails
un souci du détail qui est un prix 1000
euros pour un panier moyen dans cet
établissement
un coût qui s'explique en grande partie
par le temps qu'il faut pour réaliser le
bouquet parfait 10 à 15 minutes en
moyenne et surtout trouver les idées qui
feront la différence le jour j un
bouquet réussi dans un mariage c'est une
excellente associations de couleurs avec
un très beau camaïeu de couleurs des
couleurs qui s'associe très bien
et après le choix des fleurs le choix
des fleurs est important parce que ça va
apporter ça va apporter le le relief la
forme
une fois les fleurs sélectionner les
mariés devront également ajouter les
traditionnels faire part à la robe de
mariée les animations au total le budget
de cette journée grains peut rapidement
pour atteindre les 15000 euros en
moyenne pour cent convives sûrement le
jour le plus heureux mais aussi le plus
coûteux de leur vie